في ساعات الفجر الاولى تستفيق العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف التي يغرق جزء منها في
الظلام بسبب انقطاع الكهرباء على واقع
غارات جويه عنيفه قالت الاداره العسكريه
للمدينه انها غارات روسيه بمسيرات شاهد
الايرانيه الاداره العسكريه قالت على موقع
تيليجرام ان العدو يهاجم العاصمه كما بينت
صور هيئه الطوارئ الاوكرانيه حريقا كبيرا
في منشاه كهربائيه هذه الغارات اصابت على
ما يبدو مناطق سكنيه في محيط الكيف اهله
بالمدنيين الذين عبر بعضهم عن ياس شديد
لغياب اي افق لنهايه الحرب
اشعر بما يشعر به بقيه الناس لانني اعرف
انني لست وحدي الناس كلهم يعانون ما الذي
علي ان افعله ان نصرخ ساعدوني يمكن ان
تصرخوا ما شئته انسه كلها وبلادنا كلها
تستفيد
في هذا الوقت
هارم امريكيه مضاده للرادار في المجال
الجوي لمنطقه بيروت المتاخمه لاوكرانيا
على اراضي بيلاروسيا الحليفه لموسكو تواصل
القوات الروسيه تمارينها التكتيكيه
بالذخيره الحيه باستخدام المدرعات
والمدفعيه والمشات فيما يخشى القاده
العسكريون الاوكرانيون ان تكون هذه
التمارين جزءا من استعدادات القوات
الروسيه لشن هجوم كبير في بدايه العام
المقبل على العاصمه